Bangladesh is the world's best country
if you don't want to be alone
this country has half the population of
the United States but concentrated in an
area the size of Illinois it is the most
densely populated country on the planet
it's also been one of the fastest
growing countries in the last two
decades in less than 20 years Bangladesh
has cut poverty in half
today they are the leader in textile
manufacturing only surpassed by China in
fact I'm pretty sure your shirt your
trousers or something else you're
wearing right now was made there but
wait a minute because it is still too
soon to open the bottle of champagne
yes Bangladesh grows faster but still
today thirteen percent of their
population lives on less than $2 a day
and that's 20 million people add to this
the fact that Islam is the main religion
in the country and you get headlines
like this one terrorist activity
increased in Bangladesh in 2016
amid global fall in attacks despite the
fact that Bangladesh has a secular
Constitution adulterous women are stoned
to death in some regions and 80% of the
population agrees with changing the
legislation so that it meets the
principles of Sharia law meanwhile
despite the radicalization of some
citizens the Prime Minister Sheikh
Hasina is a woman and the opposition
leader
halida Zia is also a woman so the
situation there is far from quiet
especially given that in the next year
2018 Bangladesh will hold elections that
might be crucial for the future of the
country
so the questions that we find ourselves
asking are well can Bangladesh become an
Islamic Republic and why do we think
Bangladesh is a demographic time bomb
well today we are going to answer these
questions but before we do that let's
take a look back at the history one
country two families in 1947 the British
Empire let's the Indian colonies become
independence the parts where Hinduism
was the main religion became what today
is known as India the parts with an
Islamic majority became Pakistan but
things are not as simple as they seem
the Muslim part ended up divided into
two parts
as you can see on the screen now India
was in the middle and to the left and
right there was Pakistan with a
political system based on Sharia law two
thousand two hundred kilometers divided
these two parts that belonged to the
same state and as you can imagine this
just didn't work very well in fact
putting aside the fact that they have
the same religion these two parts while
they had nothing in common
they didn't even speak the same language
Weston Pakistanis despise the eastern
Pakistanis also known as the Bengalis
and wanted to have their own country so
in 1971 the liberation war started
estimations say that somewhere between
300,000 and 3 million civilians died in
this war but as a result a brand-new
country was born and this was the
People's Republic of Bangladesh this is
also how Mujibur Rahman or as they know
him Bunga bandulu became the first
president
so since Pakistan was an Islamic country
and Bangladesh hated Pakistan badly
Bangabandhu designed a constitution that
was completely secular in fact they
followed the ideological fashion of the
time the so called Arab socialism this
was an ideological cocktail that
combines authoritarian leaders a
centralized economy and secularism
but do wait just a minute here because
it really wasn't that easy
four years later Bangabandhu and this
whole family died in a coup d'etat made
by those who supported Pakistani rule
during the liberation war only his two
daughters survived one of them Sheikh
Hasina is the current prime minister but
let's look back at a coup d'etat after
two years of political stability in the
influence of the CIA General Zia Rahman
became the man in charge
one of the his most controversial
decisions was to give an amnesty to the
pro Pakistani therefore Islamist
soldiers who killed Banga Bantu this is
how the big ideological divide was
created in Bangladesh on the one hand we
have the family in the political party
of general Rama the BNP or Bangladesh
National Party they are a conservative
coalition with a strong presence among
Islamist parties some of those who
participated in the coup d'etat in 1975
became members of the BNP party on the
other hands we have the party of
Bangabandhu the so called Awami League
they are considered socialist and
secularist
general Raman ruled the country for four
years then of course came another coup
d'etat Bangladesh was ruled by the
military until 1991
when democracy it came back to the
country but hold on a minute again here
because the Bangladesh way of democracy
is pretty far from democratic one
country to women since 1991 those two
political parties had two main leaders
on the BNP side we have Khaleda Zia the
widow and SIA ramen on the Awami side
there is Sheikh Hasina the daughter of
Bangabandhu since then elections have
been a fight between two women this
alternate in power every five years
neither one of them can win the
elections consistently in fact elections
in Bangladesh are absolute hell
usually the opposition party organizes
violent protests and paralyzing strikes
that damage the country
but in 2006
well things they changed back then the
Awami League led by Sheikh Hasina
disagreed with the way that they
organized the elections this was pretty
business as usual but this time the
military tried to make acute it's odd
that some order in the country like they
had in the 1980s elections had to be
postponed for two years and finally
Sheikh Hasina won the elections in that
moment escena learned a lesson the
important thing is not winning the
office but keep
now remember when I told you the general
ramen gave amnesty to those who killed
Bangabandhu forty years before well his
daughter Sheikh Hasina had a pretty good
memory and she took those memories from
the past and decided to do something
about those Islamists who might
challenge her power those who
participated in the 1975 coup d'etat
punished execute leader of largest
Islamist party if this wasn't enough she
broke up one of the biggest political
traditions in Bangladesh usually during
an election the parliaments would create
a neutral government in order to
guarantee a clean and fair process but
Athena was not willing to leave power
the opposition boycotted the elections
and to see no one with 79 percent of the
vote one wish ruling party wins after
boycotted vote in other words now in
2017 Sheikh Hasina is the strongest
leader in Bangladesh's history and this
is no little thing if we remember that
this is a country of more than 160
million inhabitants so the question is
now is there anyone who can match a
Cena's power well the answer is actually
yes demographic bomb as we said at the
beginning over 20 million Bangladeshi
citizens live in extreme poverty they
are young and extremely religious in
other words they are the perfect market
for a radical Islamist movements and
yeah I know you might be saying right
now but well Simon didn't you say the
Bangladesh is one of the fastest growing
countries well yes I did and this is
exactly why those twenty million poor
citizens are a real problem
so listen if you want to start a
populist revolution never go to an
extremely poor country in fact most of
the radical movements appear when
countries are starting to grow or aren't
stepping out of a crisis this is your
window of opportunity that is the moment
when the worse off citizens can feel
jealous of those who are getting
wealthier and wealthier those 20 million
impoverished citizens are a perfect
target for radicalization and they can
be a real threat to a country's
stability this is why
terrorist attacks have been getting more
and more frequent in Bangladesh since
many of the victims are bloggers who
claims of the atheists and trying to
spread secularism in the country but the
real wake-up call that came in 2016
Bangladesh attack Isis gunmen kill at
least 22 people in a hostage crisis at
Dhaka restaurant since then Sheikh
Hasina has been trying to stop terrorism
nonetheless as I said in 2018 elections
will be held and the government's is
trying to gain support from that
religious population this is why escena
is a letting Saudi Arabia invest 1
billion dollars into the building of 560
mosques throughout the country at the
same time she is making it harder for
women to inherit money and also making
it easier for young girls to marry much
older men
but it doesn't stop there an Islamic
propaganda group called heifers at II
Islam send their agenda with 13
political suggestions to governments for
instance they wanted the religious
teachings given at radical mosques to be
considered at the same level as any
academic institution and against the
odds Sheikh Hasina has accepted that as
well as other proposals from the
radicals don't forget that she and her
party are the ones that stands for
secular values against a more
traditional approach from the BNP party
so this leads us to the big question
here do you think Bangladesh is at risk
of becoming a de facto Islamic Republic
or is this just a political game push a
casino to strengthen her power before
the elections well you can leave your
answer in the comment section below and
please do also visit our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast you can find it
at reconsider Mediacom they provided the
vocals in this video that are not mine
also check out my new channel bio
graphics we do biographies of notable
people from history as well as the
present-day
find a link to that in the description
below new videos here as well every
Monday and Thursday so subscribe to
visual politics so you won't miss
anything and as always thank you for
watching and if you want to learn more
about politics and hear even more of my
lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there